this is Session two of the foundations
of Finance module in this session I'd
like to talk about the way we think
about a Business and Finance and lay the
foundations for what I call the
corporate life cycle some a concept I'm
going to come back to over and over
again in the course of both my corporate
finance and my valuation classes so
let's think about a balance sheet a
balance sheet as seen through the eyes
of somebody in finance as opposed to
accounting and accounting balance sheet
as you know accountants break down
assets into fixed assets current assets
intangible assets financial assets and
the library decided to current libraries
long-term liability shareholders equity
and god only knows what else in a
financial balance sheet as you notice
there are only two items on each side of
the balance sheet let's take a look at
the asset side of the balance sheet in
finance we don't care about whether
assets our fixed or intangible or
current we care about whether they're in
place they're already there or whether
they will show up in the future assets
in place and growth assets assets in
place or investments you won't really
made as a company growth assets is the
value that I'm giving you because I
think you make investments in the future
next year two years out five years are
as far as the eye can see scary I'm
giving you credit for investments you
haven't even thought about yet on the
other side of the balance sheet notice
there are only two items there are only
two ways you can find a business you can
borrow the money that's dead or you can
use your own money that's equity so
let's take a closer look at each of
these items because in a sense it's
going to lay the foundations for almost
everything we don't finance let's start
with assets in place as I explained
assets in place is the value that I'm
attaching to investments you've already
made as a company let's provide some
let's think of a couple of examples if
you think of GM afford old-time
automobile companies assets in place
will be the the automobile plants the
assembly plants though the production
that they already have in life if you're
talking about Microsoft assets in place
will be Windows and Office in
assessments that Microsoft is already
made as a company you think house is any
different than what accountants are
doing here's the big difference in
finance when we think about assets in
place the question I'm asking is not how
much money have you put into these
assets you might have spent billions and
billions in these assets but frankly I
don't care what I'm talking about is the
value that I'm attaching to these assets
based on what they will produce and cash
flows in the future already you can see
that they can be a disconnect disconnect
between what what you've invested in an
asset in place and the value that I
attach to it in fact if you've invested
a lot in assets in place that are no
longer producing much in earnings the
value that I might attach to those
assets in place might be much lower than
the number you show on your accounting
balance if the assets in place have
become much more productive the value
that I can attach those assets in place
might be much greater than what you see
as capital invested if they're kind of
running in place and they're doing what
they did when you originally invested
they might be close to what you show as
capital investment your assets in place
so what do you see as the value of
assets in place in a financial balance
sheet there's not a reflection of what
you've already spent on these assets but
on what I expect you to generate as
value from these assets going into the
future
it's forward-looking not backward
looking that concept gets even more
interesting when you think about growth
assets growth assets is the value that
I'm giving for investments I expect you
to make in the future next year two
years at five years or ten years on the
value growth assets comes not from how
much money you will put into these
assets but how much excess return you
will generate from putting money to
these assets you're saying what are you
talking about so let's say you'd plan to
invest a billion dollars in new projects
next year that billion dollars has to
come from somewhere right so that by
itself is not going to add value to you
but if you can take that billion dollars
and invested in an amazing projects
project it'd make 30 40 50 percent
returns when it costs you only 10
percent raise capital there is value
added from those projects I'm going to
give you credit by giving you a value
on those growth assets but let's suppose
you invest that same billion dollars in
new projects let's say that it cost you
10% raise capital for those projects and
you make exactly 10% there is no value
in those current assets you will get
bigger as a company but you're not
adding value to your company the value
those growth assets can be zero take a
third and perverse example let's assume
you plan to invest a billion dollars
next year it costs you 10% to raise that
capital but do you think you can make
only 5% you know what you will have a
value for your growth assets on your
balance sheet but it'll be a negative
and you're actually destroying value as
you grow already you can see that growth
assets gonna have huge value for
businesses that have tremendous growth
potential and can earn great excess
returns might have no value for
companies that are running in place
could actually destroy value for
companies that are embarking on these
pathways of taking investments that
don't under a quadrate of retirement
this is something that we're going to
focus on in both corporate finance and
valuation because to me the essence of
running a good business is to make sure
you create value from growth assets and
if you cannot find that value you start
trying to create value from those assets
let's talk about death do you think
that's easy just look in the balance
sheet your content will tell you how
much you owe if only it were that simple
it's true that bank loans and corporate
bonds obviously show up in your balance
sheet but there are items that should be
treated as that that sometimes don't
show up for the moment I'm going to
leave that mysterious but I'm going to
give you three criteria that I look for
to classify something is that the first
is with that you have a contractual
commitment a contractual commitment to
make payments in the future remember
when you issue equity you might tell
people I'll pay a dividend but it's not
a contractual commitment if you don't
pay you can't get sued for not paying it
but with that you have a contractual
commitment that contractual commitment
can be to make a fixed payment or it can
be a payment that you agreed to that's
that's tied to something else floating
rate debt for instance the contractual
commitment can actually vary across time
but it's set up front
the second component of debt is that if
you fail to make that contractual
commitment bad things happen
what kind of bad things do you run a
business you could be shut down the
lenders take over your business you
default you go bankrupt and third in
much of the world not all of the world
but in much of the world that payment
you make as a contractor commitment and
debt for whatever reason the tax code
seems to be tilted towards they usually
tax reductive contractual commitment
tax-deductible loss of control those are
the features that I look for to classify
something is dead and we'll talk about
what in addition to bank loans and
corporate bonds you might end up
classifying as debt equity is a residual
claim what does that mean you get to
keep if you're the owner of a business
you get whatever cash flows are left
over after everybody else's needs have
been met so you have to pay off the
lenders you got to meet reinvestment
needs you get whatever is left over and
remember there might be nothing left
over or you might actually end up at the
hole your residual cash flow could be a
negative cash flow it is a listen to
work clay if you shut the company down
you liquidate you first have to pay off
your lenders before you get whatever is
left over if you're an equity investor
in a publicly traded company though that
residual claim is not necessarily going
to come to you because it's an
intermediary that intermediary are the
managers of the company would decide how
much of that residual cash flow they
will pay you as a dividend so the
publicly traded company what do you see
as dividends might be equal to the
residual cash flow might be much less
than the residual cash flow or might be
much more so keep that in mind when you
look at dividends the dividends are a
smoothed out version of the residual
cash flow but they might not be a
measure of the residual cash flow so
we've talked about assets in place we've
talked about growth assets we talked
about debt we've talked about equity now
let me lay out a structure that I'm
going to come back to over and over
again in my sessions to introduce other
concepts and that is the notion of a
corporate life cycle just like human
beings are born they age they mature and
then they go to decline companies are
born that's what a startup is
they're teenagers that's what a young
girl company is there in the peak of
their life that's what a growth
companies they mature and then they
going to decline and the reason I like
this structure is it allows me to think
about how that financial balance sheet
will evolve as a company ages let's
think about it for a young startup if
you think about the assets out of the
balance sheet almost all of the value is
going to come from growth assets right
what assets in place do you have as you
start to grow your your assets in place
start to accumulate but it's still the
growth assets that drive your value as
you mature as a company the assets in
place are going to become a bigger and
bigger component of your VAD like the
essence of a mature company's most of
your value comes from assets in place
less if it comes from growth assets
there will be a point in time in every
company's life though well your growth
assets are going to dry out that's when
you're going to decline all of your
value comes from assets in place in the
assets in place themselves would start
to shrink
there will be no growth assets in fact
if you try to grow you will only destroy
value even more quickly so the
composition of your assets will actually
vary depending on where you are in the
lifecycle now if you think about the way
you finance a company debt in equity
that do will vary depending upon where
you are in a business know so if you
think about the composition of debt and
of how you raise finance if you're a
young startup remember you have no
earnings yet because your assets in
place of not kicked in the primary way
in which you should fund yourself as a
business should be equity you cannot
make interest payments with promise and
potential so you should be funded almost
entirely of entirely with equity as you
mature as a company you're a young girl
company you still are primarily growth I
said you should still be funded
primarily with equity it's as you mature
that your capacity to borrow money will
open up and as your capacity to borrow
money opens up you might choose to
borrow money why because remember the
tax code rewards you for borrowing money
and that will increase the proportion of
debt
that you have on your balance sheet and
as you're going to decline remember
you're liquidating your assets you're
going to be paying off both debt and
equity your composition of debt and
equity would reflect how quickly you
liquidate so notice the advantage of
having a corporate lifecycle is it gives
you a sense of both how the asset side
of the balance sheet will evolve as well
as the library side so let's finish off
with the harvesting side you see what's
the harvesting side I think we sometimes
lose sight of the fact that the reason
we invest in businesses is not to just
see them grow that's nice but ultimately
we invest in businesses to collect on
our cash flows the endgame here is
dividends or cash flows and if you look
at how that side of odds as companies go
through the lifecycle guess what you
should expect early in the process when
you're a young startup your cash flows
are actually going to be negative you're
going to be raising capital to grow as
you grow that will probably continue
still need access to capital as you
become larger you might not need capital
as much but you still might not be in a
position to return much cash because
much of your cash will go back into the
business as you mature as a company your
capacity to return cash will increase
fear of publicly traded company managers
might still hold back on cashes which
point cash balances a company start to
accumulate but eventually that cash will
start to return to investors when you're
in decline so everything about a
business changes as it moves through the
life cycle and sometimes all you might
need to understand why a business does
what it does is ask yourself where in
the lifecycle do I think this business
is so this is a concept we will return
to over and over but remember again a
financial balance sheet is
forward-looking it's simple in the
center only two items but it's complex
in the sense that those two items
require that you know or you make your
best estimate so what do you think this
business will do in the future and how a
financial balance sheet of balls will
depend on where you are the life cycle
as a business